bullet cab show special guest we got the
homegirl beans in here yes sir we out
here her new album is out well yeah by
the time this comes out it's going to be
out yeah tables turn yep tables turn why
that name
we just decided to call it that because
like i feel like we was always so uh
well i was always so
humble and you know always kept to
myself and [ __ ] like that but on this
project me talking [ __ ] you know i'm
really talking about [ __ ] so
uh it's been a long time coming too
right yeah because is this your first
body of work since you were on the
netflix show
yeah since before that for sure like i
wanted to drop a project after the
netflix show but that didn't happen you
were dropping singles and [ __ ] though
yeah exactly my last project that i put
out was like like 2015 or 17 i think oh
[ __ ] 2017. so it's been a while yeah
it's been a minute who else on the album
you got a bunch of dope features we got
reason on there we got eric bellinger we
got
cause dizzy
i think that's it benny benny benny the
butcher song made it yeah that joints on
there too yo so uh what was it like
obviously
like knowing that like
you know i know when you work on an
album like there's
always a certain energy going into a
project but i feel like for you there's
like a lot riding on this being kind of
like your first real major look album if
that makes sense since you've kind of
had a lot of eyes on you yeah was it was
any sort of pressure or did you kind of
oh man i just feel like the music
progressively got better you know so i
feel like people are going to hear that
progress in the music so i don't feel
like there's i just feel like it worked
out you know like it's it's it's amazing
do you feel like uh because i feel like
there's
like we're in the middle of like a
female m.c like renaissance i think it's
the biggest it's ever been as far as
like just the amount of dope female
rappers and the amount of dope
successful female rappers like back in
the day we had like foxy and missy and
little kim and all that but now there's
like
but i feel like
there's not really like uh somebody who
kind of does what you do obviously rap
city is an incredible mc she's one of my
favorite mc's period but like do you
feel like you're kind of filling a void
when it comes to like the newer
generation of like female mcs absolutely
i feel like what i do like it's in a
lane that nobody else is in especially
when i start throwing this spanish in
there you know like the bars is already
out of here so when the spanish come in
too
is there any bilingual [ __ ] on the album
no
but i just wrote a freestyle last night
in spanish and that [ __ ] is gas are you
like fully bilingual yeah okay so you're
about to dip and dip your toes into both
worlds as well
as well that's how i feel it's just like
me as well i know some dope people in
the spanish you know networking and [ __ ]
like that so i was like so that's what's
next for you you could put the
outmaneuver started [ __ ] with some spit
you could start doing reggaeton
i don't know about all that but i
definitely want to you know put some
spanish into it so hey that [ __ ] is
going crazy for snow the product right
now
she's setting the world on fire she did
that what's that freestyle she did uh i
forget the name of the platform but that
[ __ ] went crazy i think it's in
argentina the spanish market is huge man
and they love that [ __ ] they love the
real rap [ __ ] it is huge
so uh you're feeling a void in this
rapture right now
uh your album has got a bunch of heavy
hitters was there anybody who
you got on the project who you were like
damn they they really did their thing i
gotta go work rework on my verse or was
everything like already kind of like nah
yeah everything was already done if we
did a feature that was something that
they put on it
but i'm saying like you you you felt
good about all your [ __ ] like hey look
like 100 yeah i always do i never felt
like i had to go back and change some
[ __ ] right who's got your favorite verse
on the album that's not your own
um
tough
probably
probably dizzy dizzy dizzy shout out to
dizzy is your cause and you guys just
put a record out too uh dizzy uh with
damrick right yeah the blessings lessons
on the way yup yeah shout out are you
gonna be doing like
having to wait so long for this album
like are you gonna is that gonna be like
your pace moving forward or now that
you're gonna get this album out of the
way you're just going to kind of
press press gas on keeping your foot on
the on the neck it's go time dropping
hella [ __ ] yeah we're going to put the
project out and then uh i'm probably
going to work on the project with
this producer that i [ __ ] with called
money money montage okay uh we'll
probably put out a joint together just
like a little ep um and i'm just kidding
so you're just gonna keep going crazy i
got bad music like already done so
what's been your best live show so far
because you've been at uh the rolling
lounge you've been doing a lot of these
dope festivals like
yeah i say it's rolling loud miami yeah
rolling out miami was a good weekend
yeah that [ __ ] was lit it was really lit
and then probably atlanta atlanta was
fun well because you were at a3c at
atlanta right how many because a3c is
like do you just do one show there do
you just bounce around the city and i
did one show i did one show and then i
slid fire
here
hey man you want all the right shows
yeah roll up
was rolling out of new york was it as
rainy as everyone made it seem like yes
the day i performed thank god it didn't
rain but every other day it was raining
it was cold it was not cool i was
shivering i was out there were you there
for any of the uh scuffling that was
happening all kinds of fights was going
down backstage i see no fights i was in
and out i really showed up and then we
did the show and then i did like press a
little bit after i was done and then you
got the hell out of there yeah i had to
get on the flight
my flight was at like eight and my
performance was at like four oh [ __ ]
the performance was in queens newark was
my flight so yeah oh yeah that's a
mission you could have just flown out of
queens
is in queens where laguardia is yeah i
think so right
yeah hey hey man we got to talk to your
booking agent that's what happens when
you don't book your own [ __ ] yeah like
that's far yeah that's a mission [ __ ] uh
anything else you got going on that like
you want to plug like you got anything
like obviously merch coming out with the
with the album yeah i'm probably gonna
drop some merch i'm probably gonna just
throw that album cover on some uh on
some on some hoodies to be honest with
you
um my little signature on there
something simple and um yeah the album
the album that's just really all we
pushing right now that [ __ ] is out right
now actually go run that [ __ ] up how
many videos do you have like in the can
because i know you've already been
dropped you've been dropping a lot of
visuals yeah we have a we probably have
like two more videos left um i'm
dropping a video on on this the data
album dropped so it's out now yeah like
the video the album is the album the
video surf with dizzy right is out right
now go get that go get that and yo is it
is pink drink your go-to at starbucks
yes so that's like if you go to
starbucks that's what you're getting
that's it that's like a child's drink
they need to pay me that's what my
that's what my son gets he's like dad i
want the pig drink he said
a child's drink i'll be getting that
iced black coffee you didn't mean no
sugar no cream just never went to
starbucks and got coffee really ever in
my life oh god bless you so you're not a
coffee drinker not really damn coffee
[ __ ] my stomach up yeah coffee will get
have you on the toilet for sure it's a
laxative for sure well look hey we're
gonna have you do your thing
uh because beans is one of the the
nicest on the microphone so it's only
right we have her bless the mic one time
all right uh yo man i'm gonna have my
guy cook cook cook hit uh hit
new album out right now tables turn out
down
look look i just get up and i'm ready to
get it yeah no he don't love me he just
be worried about what i'm spitting yeah
i ain't buying him [ __ ] you lucky if you
get it running yeah real [ __ ] no
pretending huh i'm the bestest for the
record huh count the green like lettuce
yeah tables turn out now [ __ ] you
better tune in
[ __ ] my whole work i've been out here on
some new [ __ ] yeah the money calling saw
pick up from me my blue strips yeah and
they know that i'm hot somehow i still
give them this cool [ __ ] you hoes they
never seen nothing like it that's why
they be looking amazed it's like when
they see me they get excited but still
ain't got nothing to say i keep it short
i am the source i am just turning the
page playing a sport opening doors i
just been learning the game yeah and you
know i'm the one i just do this for fun
look at what i be come you rap [ __ ]
is done i've been stacking these funds
these are hundreds not ones i'm outside
going dumb yeah
running up a mile on them he want me to
smile for [ __ ] use the wildcard on my
own [ __ ] i'm out doing switching up the
style on them i need to get out more
outside i'm outdoors like bees why you
acting out for it's only right my ex
know i'm as cold as ice say you miss me
it's a lonely night i ain't going back
can't hold me right yeah all with life
cause it just happened how i supposed to
be some off can't get close to me cause
i'm too hot man you know it's me yeah
yeah baby
make sure y'all tune it go get that
album all right new video out with dizzy
right two go support that [ __ ] shout out
to the homegrown beans that beans got
bars on the ig all of that all that run
it up
[Music]